Derek you and your sister have such a  fun competitive relationship she just  got done with grease flies  you know well I will say Greece  definitely raised the bar as far as the  way it was shot and the way it was done  and you know for this musical ways it's  it kind of lends himself to that similar  style I suppose and we have a great team  amazing directors and amazing camera  operators so we're actually actually  building a studio for like just for this  so it's pretty incredible so they  actually it's like this like we were on  the University of the day and it was  just this frame of a studio nothing  there yet so we're gonna be like  christening this brand new play